hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an Australian science fiction
film called other life spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the opening scene features the Amari
siblings attired in Black wetsuits at
the beach the sister Ren wants to go for
a swim but her brother Jared is a bit
nervous as she is scared of high tides
nonetheless after a bit of insisting he
joins her in the water and the two have
a lot of fun subsequently the scene
transitions to a vivid and changing
pattern showing A View From the window
of a building Ren awakens with a stream
of black fluid dripping from her eye she
is seen sitting on the floor with empty
plastic eye drop containers Ren is the
lead researcher at a technology firm she
co-founded with an entrepreneur Named
Sam using nanotechnology she invented
other life a biological form of virtual
reality that can generate lifelike
memories using it one can travel to a
completely different environments and
enjoy themselves with the utmost Freedom
right now the product has not been made
available to the market and ren is
testing it on herself she is usually
supervised by her colleague Byron Finbar
however unbeknownst to the others she is
also secretly testing the product on her
comatose brother here it is revealed
that Jared accidentally drowned when
they went swimming Ren managed to save
him but by that time extensive damage
had been done to his brain from that day
on she has been blaming herself for her
brother's condition in the next scene
Ren is seated with the Drug
Administration team and one of the
interviewers remarks on her outstanding
academic achievements which ceased four
years ago Ren claims it was caused by an
accident where her brother almost
drowned the panel considers other life
to be a challenging technology to
classify but Ren describes it as a form
of biological software rather than a
drug in other words it's like a really
good drug she explains that it allows
one to program new experiences that are
chemically indistinguishable from
reality the interviewers also bring up
Ren's father who had previously
expressed concerns about the potential
dangers of prolonged exposure to her
technology including the risk of
seizures and brain death Ren
acknowledges that there are risks
because an abuse of any substance
whether it be an apple or what can be
dangerous that's true too many Apple
products and you become a dork late Ren
is experimenting with a snowboarding
experience in which she climbs a snowy
mountain and descends down however the
program suddenly goes through a
technical issue which causes the whole
experience to repeat upon Awakening Ren
discovers that she has been immersed in
the other life world for six days
already despite encountering technical
glitches she remains optimistic about
fixing them and believes that other life
will be a popular product in the future
on the other hand the entrepreneur Sam
is pitching the other life concept to
investors assuring them that the product
can be marketed as a near instantaneous
experience that can last for days all of
our customers are going to
themselves literally it's going to be
great after the meeting Sam and ren have
a disagreement about the future
direction of the company Ren is dealing
with a lot of problems and in the midst
of it all her romantic relationship with
a co-worker named Danny suffers due to
her lack of time later that night Ren
and Byron successfully identify the
error in the code and test the revised
version without any further issues it
appears that she has completed 482 tests
each one of them course responds to
approximately 20 days in other life a
few days later Ren returns to the
hospital to test the other life on her
brother once more and this time his eye
twitch is giving her a glimmer of hope
unfortunately when she shares it with
the doctor he tells her that it is a
common occurrence in comatose patients
surely Ren would have known that by now
the following day Ren visits her father
who is a professor at a college they
discuss other life and its potential to
help Jared come out of his coma Ren
expresses her confidence that the
glitches in the tech are merely a result
of bad code but her father disagrees he
argues that mental conditions such as
anxiety and depression are also a type
of bad code Ren becomes upset with her
father feeling that he has given up on
her brother and warns him against
unplugging Jared without her consent
however the old man dismisses her and
walks away while at work Sam and Byron
find out that the amount of nanites
being used are much higher than what Ren
has reported they ask her what
simulation she's been running but she
doesn't disclose any details saying that
it's still experimental a few moments
later Sam and adrenor alone when she
shares his most recent idea he wants the
government to license their product for
use as an alternative to prisons
according to Sam the inmates would be
trapped inside their own heads for years
while only a minute passed in real time
alleviating prison overcrowding however
Ren firmly declines The Proposal saying
it's not applicable following this she
heads out of the building and comes
across Danny the two are meeting after a
long time apart so they decide to spend
some private time together once they are
done having coitus Wren allows him to
try the snowboarding experience in other
life which he thoroughly enjoys after
this she gets back to work while Danny
grabs another eye drop and tries it
unaware that it is the experimental one
she designed for Jared this causes him
to suffer from violent seizures and when
Ren notices this she immediately calls
9-1-1 unfortunately Danny is unable to
survive in the next scene when Sam finds
out about the incident he confronts Ren
and angrily questions her about the
experience that caused Danny's death it
appears that all of the experiences have
been thoroughly tested and approved
except for that one this causes a major
backlash in the media and the officials
are on the verge of shutting down the
company however Sam is not going to let
that happen so easily using his
influence and wealth he strikes a deal
in which the government agrees to drop
all charges and in exchange Ren will
have to spend one year of solitary
confinement in other life when the
latter learns of this she is furious
that Sam went behind her back and
commercialized this idea however for the
sake of their company she agrees to be a
part of it following this they all
proceed to the testing room where Bayern
administers the eye drop to ran the next
second she finds herself in a small room
that consists of basic necessities of
life including bottled water canned tuna
sleeping mat tablet pen and a toilet
that tablet better have mystery recapped
says Ren Ren begins to spend her time
working out eating and taking notes on
her tablet the room she is confined and
also has a screen displaying the number
of days she is spent there for the first
few days Ren is depressed remembering
Danny and her brother from the past but
with each day that passes she becomes
more hopeful that she can still bring
her brother back using codes eventually
a year passes and ren expects to return
to her real world however she crumbles
when the confinement counter is reset to
zero zero one without her release this
is when Ren realizes that the exit code
is failed prompting her to panic she
yells and breaks things around her in
Rage
of those days not long after she
discovers a gap inside the hatch which
she dislodges in order to make her way
out as Ren exits the confinement room
she comes across a storage area with
food and water as well as a monitoring
room from which she was being watched
this makes her realize that she has been
imprisoned in a real world cell the
entire time just then a guard comes
running towards her but Ren is not going
to stay in the confinement anymore hence
she steals a vehicle and flees the area
outside Ren notices a busy road with
other life advertisements everywhere
alarmed she heads to her workplace only
to discover that it is empty she then
goes to the police station where the
officer shockingly reveals that rent has
been recorded as living in Italy for the
past year upon hearing this she attempts
to explain that she is the co-founder of
other life and that she has been held
captive in herself for the past year
however when they go to investigate the
cell it has already vanished this makes
the police suspicious about her story so
they simply ask her to go home feeling
lost and unsure of whom to trust Wren
goes to the apartment she used to live
in but she finds someone else residing
there a short while later Sam shows up
and offers to take her somewhere safe
but Ren who doesn't believe him anymore
runs away from there she then seeks
Refuge with her trustworthy colleague
Cass who lets her in and provides her
with food after a while Cass reveals
that everyone assumed Ren had cashed out
and left for Italy it was apparently a
rumor that the cunning Sam had spread so
as to not arouse any suspicion at this
point Ren is having a hard time
processing everything around her but
Cass finally gives her some good news
she discloses that Dany is actually
alive he never died as the doctors
managed to resuscitate him a week after
Ren's imprisonment that night the couple
finally reunites and they promise to
never leave each other again later the
trio heads to a restaurant where they
discuss the events of the past year Ren
discovers that other life has become a
major success and is currently being
used for a variety of purposes including
long-term confinements she then decides
to get to the bottom of what happened
and Danny suggests that she go to the
media and expose Sam how however Wren
says that she doesn't have any evidence
against him in the next scene using
cass's ID card Ren and Danny sneak into
the other life building and start
looking for her previous data inside
they come across Byron who is also
revealed to be one of the conspirators
behind the whole Scandal Dany
immediately restrains him allowing Ren
to search for the data shortly after she
manages to locate the hard drive but by
this time Byron has already alerted
security the couple somehow manages to
flee the scene after which they get into
a car along the way Ren discloses that
they will need a printer to prepare the
chemical but since all the other life
offices in the city are on high alert
they cannot go there suddenly she
remembers that she had kept one at her
father's home in the woods so the couple
quickly heads there upon arriving they
find the house empty and ren gets to
work she spends the whole night trying
to prepare the chemical and in the
process she falls asleep the next day
Ren's father returns home and she
confides in him about everything this
time the old man is willing to support
her Mission now with renewed motivation
Ren gets back to work and it doesn't
take her much time to create a new more
advanced prototype of other life wasting
no time she drives to the hospital and
administers it to her brother
surprisingly The Chemical Works and
Jared wakes up making Ren very happy
however her joyous short-lived as the
poor guy suddenly starts having seizures
when the situation gets worse a
distraught Ren pulls the plug finally
letting her brother pass away in peace
just when it appears that the drama is
over Ren starts to experience fragmented
memories of the testing room with people
yelling and Byron urging her to wake up
it is revealed that her supposed Escape
was part of an other life glitch during
her year-long imprisonment this means
that all of her post-incarceration
experiences were also part of an
interactive other life experience now
Ren finds herself alone on the beach and
she walks alone into the water letting
the waves wash over her the water
transforms into kaleidoscopic imagery
whoa and she suddenly awakens in the
testing room after going through all of
this Ren takes some time to calm herself
down before heading to Sam's cabin she
then announces that she will take a
Hiatus from the company to concentrate
on R D she will leave the company to Sam
but will keep the patent later after run
attends Danny's funeral she suddenly
gets a call from Sam asking her to come
to the testing room to see something
important when she arrives she finds Sam
and Byron reviewing her experience the
cunning entrepreneur points at a section
of her brain scan that corresponds to
Her Interactive experience he says that
she miraculously managed to escape the
virtual prison and it could be a major
breakthrough for their future plans Sam
now wants her to take part in yet
another test to find more conclusive
results but when Ren refuses he abruptly
administers the chemical in her eyes
forcing her into the same cell Byron
reluctantly goes along with it when Sam
says it's the only way to compel Ren's
assistance in the other world Ren
manages to calm herself down allowing
the simulation to run faster and the
loop infinitely soon after she wakes up
on her own in the real world hence
beating the virtual prison twice however
this time an angry Ren is not going to
let things slide so easily she wipes the
chemical from her eyes and quickly into
Sam's trapping him in his own year-long
other life imprisonment the program
experiences a bug that endangers his
life but Ren refuses to let Sam Escape
until he serves the full 365 days she
even waits for a few extra days so that
he can experience her Agony when the
countdown reset to zero once Sam
recovers Ren leaves him to sob in the
chair the movie ends as she and her
father head to the hospital and
tearfully unplugged Jared's life support
Wren then goes to the same Beach and
watches the ocean reminiscing about the
good times spent with her late brother
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching